i want you all to see this story from
the from the new york daily news and i
want to make sure we give you all the
new ones and understanding it
just 10 violations so far under new york
city's vaccine mandate for businesses
10.
it's like the golden the golden chalice
at the end of the rainbow now you could
say
it's because everyone fell in line
immediately so there's nothing to
enforce
i don't think that's true let me read a
little bit more to give you the full
nuance and then we will provide you with
witness testimony backing up what i'm
saying now it's not just 10 violations
they also say there were 21 000
inspections so they are actually trying
to enforce this 21 000 yeah inspections
5 800 warnings were administered for
issues related to the vaccine mandate
including failure to post written policy
on premises but failure to post policy
is not the same as actually issuing a
violation to somebody because they
didn't do it
10 means they either are unwilling to or
incapable of enforcing this now let me
ask someone who is uh lives in new york
well you don't live in new york but you
are frequent to new york very often yes
yes have uh tell me what's going on i
mean
i go i go there for weeks at a time and
honestly i haven't seen any business
promoting these mandates that's awesome
i really haven't but i live in you know
like when i when i go there i stay in
old school brooklyn
and
i've never if anything i've seen people
with signs that say you know
the whole you know we don't discriminate
with sex race um gender
uh sexual orientation or and then it
says on the bottom or vaccination status
like i've seen more people putting up
those there was a there was an activist
i retweeted forgive me i forgot your
name but um he he put up these flyers he
was handing them out to businesses and
businesses were like yes yes we'll do
this
and it started that image started with
one like delhi i think was on the upper
west side of new york this is manhattan
and then
an activist went around handing them out
and now so you're saying you see more of
those than the other side i do i do i
see more of that i think that new
yorkers are slowly waking up i mean
finally got rid of cuomo the person
that's
coming at coming after him isn't much
better probably probably she's probably
worse actually but
at least they're waking up to some
of the of the the authoritarian you know
you know socialist communist but
everything they're breaking up to it
hearing this story that only there's
only been 10 violations
hearing what you say having been there
and then hearing that people across the
country are chaining f joe biden i've
never been more optimistic the uh the
premier of new south wales resigned
obviously supposedly unrelated not to
covet but when she resigned you see
eruptions of cheering in these
bars and places where people are
watching they the public support for her
is nil well there's also massive
protests all over the world from italy
to france to the united kingdom to
sweden to ireland all parts of the
united states even protest in new york
city where there's even some reports of
blm literally marching with trump
supporters and i saw photos of this and
this is an incredible moment this is
really a a
unifying moment and we have to
understand this i still want to go to
the backdrop of the last story we talked
about because social media
and and and you know the big
corporations the big monopolies out
there shape our reality they don't want
to show us that there's a lot of
resistance to this they don't want to
show us that there's a lot of protest to
this there's a reason the melbourne
police in australia are trying to block
all helicopter footage of inside of that
city so they can't show the masses of
people that have assembled coming
together to literally stand up against
the utter evisceration of total freedom
and liberty in that country so there is
a movement happening there is a wave
there is an energy and and it could go
either way it could go towards a
positive way or or a negative way it can
go total enslavement it could
can happen in any moment but but this is
go time this is again one of the reasons
why i'm here right now because i see it
i i know it and this is this is the
cornerstone moment right now here luke
calls me up and he's like tim i've been
on the show in a minute and i was like i
know he's like but it's got to that
point and i was like i know and he's
like i'll be there is that the call yeah
nice
i want to go ahead no i'm sorry no then
luke just slammed it into drive and he
and here you go i was going to say
talking about the cults going back in
social media controlling everything i
actually have a video coming up about
how
if you just look at the psychology of a
cult
it's it's fairly obvious
how they're doing this with young women
again my videos focus on women most of
the time
there's there's five things that colts
focus on one of them is or rather the
people that they go after those who want
to feel validated young women
those seeking an identity
young women
[Music]
those who are more followers not leaders
unfortunately young women yeah which is
why i continuously aim to empower women
um
those who constantly blame others
is not necessarily young women but it's
young people yeah
and people are people and leftists yeah
people are people who have very low
self-worth and people who are very angry
yeah are very easily influenced and
become uh are the most likely people to
be in involved in cults yeah if they can
make you hate yourself they can they
could change your perception about how
you see yourself they could change your
perception about how you see the world
and that's another gross power that they
have been leveraging that they have been
pushing that they have been manipulating
there's a reason again big tech social
media youtube even twitter facebook who
who was their first targets cultural
figures people independent journalists
people that were providing information
people that were going against the
agenda meanwhile there was isis on the
platform there was taliban on the
platform there was people that were
hurting children on the platform there's
people that were exploiting children
that's not for our safety and then and
now they have the gall to to tell you we
need to fight medical disinformation for
your health and safety you're the one
causing people to be depressed you're
the one causing people to commit suicide
you're the one causing people to hurt
each other you're the one literally
causing havoc and pain on the rest of
the world you have this at your
fingertips you knowingly are doing this
and you're telling me i can't even
question the medical establishment i
can't even question pfizer that has a
criminal past i i i don't want to get
this show in trouble i got a lot more to
say and you know we can recognize her
all day and night i want to clarify
you say that they're causing it and the
argument they're going to give you is
we're not causing it other people are
doing it and we're just we're just a
platform then why not
the timeline well let me explain if you
go in the middle of the street and you
sit down and block traffic you're not
doing anything you're just sitting there
but you're actually doing something
passively by blocking traffic so them
not solving it is them doing it it's not
just that they carefully curate what you
see
they make sure your perception is shaped
by what they want you to see voices that
they don't like that go against their
agenda that go against their narrative
they get censored they get shadow banned
they get demonetized their
infrastructure their businesses their
their way of living literally gets taken
away from them let me let me just let me
just throw some out there so uh we've
got right now watching 41 605 people and
last week when we had on the founder
from library a competitor to youtube boy
were our views down and people were
complaining they couldn't find the
podcast so when you have a store a title
and a video that says like facebook was
taken down which is the title of this
featuring youtuber and youtuber face
youtube's like this is fine there's no
red flags here when you have an episode
where you have the name
of the founder of library libertarian
new hampshire free state project guy all
of a sudden we're just we just no one's
getting notified that we went live and
you see how it's played they don't you
got to be careful right so so most of
you have heard this from me before but
for those who haven't ebay this is the
ebay story i know bear with me guys for
those who haven't heard it have you ever
heard the ebay story no so when ebay
started it was yellow this is like maybe
this story's apocryphal but uh it was
yellow and then one day they said we're
gonna make it white but then all of a
sudden all of their users revolted and
they were like uh it's awful it's too
bright i don't like it make it yellow
again so they change it back but then
every day over the next year they they
sh they shifted it one shade towards
white
then within a year it was a white
website and no one cared facebook
noticed the same thing remember in the
early days facebook would roll out this
update and everyone go oh everything's
all different i don't like it so they
started updating only one thing at a
time for different groups of people so
that people would be like hey did you
notice this change no okay whatever i
guess to stop the shock
that's exactly what they're doing with
censorship especially on youtube and
other platforms so you know i'll we'll
try to use it to the best of our
abilities before it happens but they
don't outright ban people who are having
conversations within the rules they just
make sure certain conversations can't be
heard they'll they'll down rank
conversations that may threaten youtube
and they'll ignore things that they
think has no relevance towards it at all
alex jones of course gets completely
nuked off the platform for what like you
know year-old comments or whatever he
gets sued for decade old comments or
whatever they really go after you if if
you're really actually threatening the
machine and alex jones was influential
he does say a lot of kooky crazy things
he does say a lot of crazy things it
turned to be right but he was
influential in helping trump get support
mic drop yeah was gonna say no one has
anything to do everybody agrees with it
i'm looking at luke
yeah thinking about the slow boil tactic
that's what i was gonna say about the
frogs
the gay frogs
i was gonna say the same thing if you if
you a frog will jump out of the pot if
you put it in boiling water but if you
leave it it'll cook itself if you boil
it slow if you do it slowly it'll cook
itself to death i was thinking the same
thing when you said that someone someone
soup yeah someone super chatted us
saying that wasn't true i don't know but
it's still it's still a good say it's
still a good concept even if it's not
true we've got because it makes sense we
have people in the super chat who are
like the comic book guy from the
simpsons actually kim
the thing about the frogs isn't true and
uh and we accept those corrections thank
you very much good audience there's also
oh i think this black list this social
black listing i'm still interested in
what you're about to say there is is is
devastating and that they can do it in
private is really unethical oh yeah did
people's private dms private messages
that you could like i could text you on
facebook about like a medication that's
on some blacklist word and then all of a
sudden they're like oh we're going to
down rank crossland's stuff from now on
so we're going to make him see a tenth
of the people 10th of his followers will
not see it instead but i don't know what
happened
that's that's
madly unethical i know they're a private
company but i also know they have 1.8
billion users per day so it's kind of a
common public company as well
well we know what they're censoring but
let's talk about what they're promoting
they're promoting mainstream media trash
they're promoting a lot of garbage
they're promoting a lot of fake news
they're promoting a lot of
disinformation that has been knowingly
corrected that knowingly was brought out
in false pretenses that knowingly misled
the general public that knowingly led to
harm in many instances i mean cnn
uh there's even arguments to make
against fox news msnbc all the major big
channels ran with fake news that had
major implications on people's lives and
existences and they never felt the
ramifications of it i sneezed the other
way and i have to look out to make sure
my video doesn't get uh rated for as an
adult content uh and age restricted uh
because i showed a video of a police
officer being too close to another
person and scaring them and i'm like
this is absolutely absurd they play by
different set of rules and they want to
make sure that you only are able to
listen to the narrative you're only able
to listen to anderson cooper and
whatever other celebritar do they have
for you that they push in front of you
that is willing to regurgitate their
talking points and do whatever uh
for a paycheck and and that's exactly
what we see
i was gonna say i'm living proof of that
i think that i've been making the same
type of content for 10 years on youtube
sexually as sexually explicit as it gets
you know what i mean talking about sex
talking about relationships reviewing
sex toys and stuff
i never once got demonetized by youtube
until i came out as leaning more
conservative on certain issues not once
when did it happen
right after i came out right after i
came out i didn't even come out as
conservative i i came out as leaving the
left that's all that i said i'm no
longer a part of these people i do not
want to be involved with them i think
they're a cult i said that kind of stuff
tim actually helped me write the script
for that thank you tim and sydney um
i don't i i said i don't want to be a
part of these people's you know
narrative anymore i don't agree with
mostly anything they say and i got
demonetized a month after that and then
and then i was monetized for like three
months and then i got demonetized again
and then i got demonetized again
and for sexually explicit content my
videos got less sexually explicit over
the years so how does that make any
sense thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you